rural broadband provision is one of the
biggest challenges in Europe and I have
with me savvier Rodriguez Martin who has
achieved some outstanding delivery with
broadband in that very area savvy eight
very excited to talk to you this morning
tell us about what you've been doing in
Portugal yeah I think that we have been
doing something different in the sense
of bringing the broadband benefits to a
real involved in brief environment we
are creating a new narrative for rural
broadband offering or creating the
conditions through our networks for the
retail operators which are our clients
to bring exactly the same kind of
packages triple-play packages at exactly
the same price that they are offering or
they have been offering in a new running
but in your own environment for the last
year's so that's a real novelty this is
not happening everywhere and you know
broadband is the utility of the telecoms
for the 20th 21st century so it's
absolutely fundamental to create the
conditions at the institutional level at
the financial level for that to happen
and you did a lot of this with FTTH yes
yes ftth was the driver of the
deployment of this network because
paradoxically today the main driver of
innovation is at the residential level
they kind of bandwidth that the
youngster that our family required is
sometimes much higher than the bandwidth
that the small and medium enterprises
require so in terms of content intensive
applications and of course and the
demand of network associated to that
ftth is really the source of innovation
and the driver of the deployment of of
fiber-optic networks in autocross 0
that's brilliant news for FDA especially
in rural areas what are some of the
benefits that you've seen as a result of
some of the application first of all
it's a matter of social justice people
living in the countryside have the right
to have access to the same conditions
that people have in the cities because
today broadband is at the core of
entertainment education working at home
we have to fix the population
the in the rural parts of the country
and giving them the tools in order to
explore their creativity we in start-up
companies we have to techna Phi the
agribusiness for instance and we need
communications with a lot of information
you need all that for the different
facets of the life of the people in the
government area for instance the
internal part of the country has
suffered much more from the closing of
schools and from the closing of health
centers so now we have an incentive and
we have the availability of the network
to support the offline to online
migration so I think that it's
absolutely necessary to give everybody
in Europe the same conditions to prosper
in their life and to have a richer life
how have you managed it what's the
secret give us a tip the rest of Europe
can follow I mean first of all we have
to find the right financial model and
that is different in every country
depending on the level of competition
depending on the level of public money
that is the seed of all this because
this dis net what did not exist in
because it was not economical for any
operator to build this network alone so
we had the condition the Portuguese
government created the conditions to
subsidize part of this network with the
requirement of this network to be an
absolutely open network natural network
something which in theory happens in
everywhere but in practice do not have
it does not happen so this is a real
open network we have put private money
on top of that and we have created a
model which is very linear min we expect
to be a BDA positive in our first year
of operation and that's a requirement to
have the expiration to have a net profit
in the years to come so the model should
be sustainable the operation should be
lean and mean and it should be relevant
to the clients and that is of course I
mean the source of of sustainability of
profitability of any investment and off
any telecom network the way
congratulations on what your retainer
thank you for talking like a very much
thank you very much so an amazing
example there of ftth leading a major
rural deployment in portugal